oh I got it I got your on the inside of
course you're going to got it
I still got it we're screwed box out box
out box out box out box out hey what I'm
on the armrest bul Jabal every time you
buy me at lunch I deduct that from the
concert ticket
we're going back to Van Halen it's win
by two we've always said it's win by
colic God we're done we're gonna hurt so
bad the differ swing you making groan
you're not making Pro was about eight
inches of height and then like being
count now when I just thought up what no
damn Oh shotgun
punch buggy oh you're telling me right
now that mr. Crespo was hotter than mrs.
McKay she was hotter after she had the
baby she had bigger boobs yes I can get
lower get lower I can get lower lower
and get lower that makes her look hotter
than your wife know what you get the
white controller your feet smell oh they
smell fine they smell like an athlete's
Beach should I convert better than you
oh hey my mom make it take it let's not
make a ticket well bar fight brawl right
now I would literally knock your head
off penis so in front of these women
telling me the Fred Taylor is better
than Brunel I'm telling you that Fred
Taylor's better how are we related so it
does look like the runs yeah wait what'd
you say brother all right okay okay okay
all right ha ha ha nerd add sores being
such a earlier turn man brothers Nutella
oh you oh you
i'ma get that let me go papa